so the weak criticism i mean it's kind
of like a meme at this point
to me at least because i've been hearing
this for a long time is oh this is
indentured servitude slavery how dare
you and i'm like that's literally the
opposite of what this is right like if
you want
you know i'm giving you money with no
strings attached i don't own any of your
work product this isn't a record label
deal right i understand that if you
don't think about it you might jump to
that conclusion very quickly right but
it's actually exactly the opposite of
what this is if anything if you want to
be political about it i make the
argument that debt looks a heck of a lot
more like indentured servitude than what
we're doing here yeah i mean it
basically is the same device indentured
servitude and debt were the same device
you owe me money in one case it was
massively predatory and i guess if we
argued higher education used to be cool
like in our generation and then it
became
pretty gnarly today yeah i mean look
again i don't i think these things are
all products that have their purpose and
time in place but i think they're really
important they understand what we're
doing is we don't own any work product
we make no decisions you know people
have talked about right there have been
some experiments before that i've seen
on the internet of people being like oh
i sold shares of myself to my friends
and they vote as a board on what whether
who i date or something and you're like
that's like the opposite like that's
ridiculous you know you don't you know
you don't have to do anything under our
deal like we're just doing a long you
know long-term you know uh arrangement
you know that is completely hands-off so
i think that's like the weak criticism
look i mean the the stronger criticism i
actually say is economic right um and
here's here's some of the problems we
face one
there's no data to back test this model
on so you say what is five percent of
marina's earnings worth right really
we have to come to an arrangement and
have a model we run but until we've done
this a bunch pricing it properly is very
hard to know right and that's like a
legitimate criticism
second legitimate question there's no
downstream market right so unite you
know you and i are early stage investors
we invest and then someone else comes
and marks us up and someone takes it
public and there's a whole system right
there's no ecosystem here right yeah i
mean she's one of one deal right so
there's no ecosystem so until there's an
ecosystem there's actually in some ways
a financial penalty to that right like
from you think from a strict financial
perspective in terms of how you can
price these things so look i'm not
afraid of the criticism i i have to
admit i kind of thrive on being told i'm
wrong so i'm happy to be told i'm wrong
about all these things i do think
sometimes you just have to go after i
mean if you're doing something
innovative like there's going to be
questions and so just thinking this
through if she became
the ultimate
you know
social media star uh they tend to
generate 20 30 40 50 million dollars a
year in revenue that is like what
youtubers do and then if you had kim
kardashian maybe on the margins it could
be a hundred million a year today
i think the reality is i think that's
today and i think the reality is when
you think forward i think there's a
strong argument that the power of the
best personalities and brands will only
increase in the coming years so you know
we'll see what this looks like in 10
years or more i mean i think
you know we'll say i believe there
should be a whole financial ecosystem
around this i believe that actually you
know crypto will help accelerate our
move into that much faster right you can
think about how so well you think about
like how are we going let's pretend
someday not today in 10 years we want to
ipo marina right or to sell our shares
in marina in some way shape or form for
liquidity for our investors you know is
marina going to be listed on the new
york stock exchange
hard to see that tomorrow right yeah
it did happen with david bowie right he
sold i think the rights to his music
yeah yeah and the bowie bonds is
different because it was bowie bonds but
it was actually secured by his catalog
right which is the opposite of what
we're doing so like
slightly backward looking instead of
forward-looking yeah exactly so so
but it is possible i think you know with
you know think of the lieberman's code
like could that ever go public
absolutely sure like and we'll see how
that works but i think you know the
reality is crypto just allows you to
compose new financial markets much more
easily ever than before and so yeah you
know when you squint because we were
long-term investors here you know slow
ventures we think from the long term
it's like
in 10 years how do these things
intersect do you get new pools of
liquidity do you get new pools of
interest in it i mean i think you can
see how these things come together if
not exactly at least thematically
and if she creates a company and she
winds up owning 50 of it which is
possible as a solo founder even 40
hey you could wind up owning five
percent of the own two percent of it if
she creates the next skims or
whatever linkedin you know you could
have multiple i mean yeah or multiple i
mean i think the thing to keep in mind
is just
the the tailwind is towards creators in
these kind of communities being more and
more powerful
and look as early as investors we always
just want to be aligned with the with
the with the founders anyway like what
are you really doing like you're
investing in a company half the time as
a seed
investor and you think the thing is
going to pivot 10 times before you know
what you've invested in anyway you're
fundamentally backing the people right
so when you kind of miss these ideas
together it just seems logical to just
directly invest in the people
do you want to increase your online
security well don't we all
if so you need to hear about nordvpn
nordvpn offers a vpn that stands for
virtual private network with benefits
such as helping customers stay safe
online and you get to access content
from over 59 different countries by
changing your virtual location with just
one click and you're never gonna miss
your favorite show again
this keeps you safe while using public
wi-fi which can be a gold mine for
hackers i tell you this because i have
sensitive information i use nordvpn to
protect myself anytime my phone my ipad
my laptop my chromebook is out on the
road i need to protect myself and i was
in italy the girls wanted to watch
something on disney plus it was like we
don't have disney plus in italy ah boom
put my vpn on we're back in the game
nordvpn has an amazing cyber month deal
for my listeners twist listeners it's
amazing how affordable vpns are you can
now get in the united states i kid you
not nordvpn for about three dollars a
month go to
nordnordvpn.com twist or use the code
twist at checkout and you're going to
get i kid you not 73 percent off your
two-year plan plus a bonus just buy the
two-year plan this way you don't have to
worry about it you need to be safe and
your vpn is how you're going to do that
nordvpn.com twist